Louisa is in Atlanta Georgia
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Louisa
what's up hi Dave thank you for taking
my call we do have a date for $60,000
and I would like to know if it is a good
idea to get a loan against the house
which is already being paid off not if
we can help but I would avoid it what
kind of dad have you got we have like
$21,000 the balance on our car and then
credit cards that uh that we have and
actually of about $40,000 on credit
cards yes okay how long have you been
doing that recently we had yeah we use
all our emergency funds viewed through a
loss in our family so all the funds were
gone and we have to get the credit cards
and then you know stuff from the house
that broke down and there are more than
$10,000 so we had to have it that is the
reason why we went up to up to $4,000
mmm so you guys all lose your jobs no
okay
so you had income coming in during this
time I know it will be like about a
thousand I mean sorry
six thousand sixty thousand dollars a
year between both of us I haven't just
got a better income from his job okay
well that's good news all right no I
would sell your car okay I would not
you've got a real mess with credit cards
here I would cut them up and vow to
never use them again no matter what
happens and but if before I would borrow
I wouldn't borrow on my house to buy a
$21,000 car when I make sixty and
essentially that's what you're asking me
to do and so I would not do that
I would probably move out of this car
and downing car dramatically and then be
able to and
pay cash for whatever you move into and
then let's attack the credit cards
smallest to largest using the debt
snowball in that order list them
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one and
attack the little one
what what's concerning me is this okay
and I want you guys to go back on
dresses you don't have to answer me but
you and your husband need to answer this
question okay what are you gonna do next
time there's a problem okay you got to
have an emergency fund in place of three
to six months of expenses once you get
this debt paid off and what kind you
know is the type of problem that
occurred ever gonna happen again or was
it just an unusual never happen again
type thing or was this a thing that
stuff comes up and we just instead of
working our way through it and instead
of limiting what we bought we just put I
mean you're making 60,000 you put
another 40,000 on credit cards so you
had $100,000 problem I mean that done
the sound right kiddo I don't think that
happened as a matter of fact I'm
questioning you so I want you guys to do
some soul-searching because sometimes
what happens is is that there's a
problem in a family like someone's ill
or there's some kind of a crisis and
while that's going on we go do a bunch
of other stupid stuff and then we blame
it on the crisis but I bet you if you go
back and detail out the $40,000 or the
credit card debt that only a portion of
it is associated with your crisis and
that's what I normally find in 30 years
of doing what I do so I really want you
guys to look at that because I'm not
positive I'm just but based on my
experience that's what I think has
happened